welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and The Walking
Dead is back with its six episode of the
season that sees negan joining up with
the whisperers to show who the true
alpha is episode 6 asks if he's better
than beta and showcases that there's
more to his plan than meets the eye
throughout this video I'm gonna be
breaking down everything that you need
to know about the latest entry as well
as what we can take from its ending
there will be heavy spoilers here so if
you haven't had a chance to watch the
episode yet then I highly suggest that
you turn off now that's your last chance
to back out but without the way I just
want to give a huge thank you for
clicking this video now let's get into
episode 6 of season 10 okay so just a
quick recap on the season so far
alpha has been launching strategic
attacks against the survivors in order
to wear them out so that she can launch
a master plan and take them down we
haven't had full confirmation on exactly
what this is just yet however it does
seem to be in order to get Lydia back
during these attacks whilst the group
were tied up with other priorities
negan has managed to escape an episode
six picks up in the midst of this with
him being brought into the fray of the
whisperers the episode itself titled
bonds circulates around this motif with
it displaying how some bonds hold us
back whilst others ties together and
make us stronger they also play
physically into the episode with them
being used for hostage taking we open
with Carol and Daryl apparently going on
the hunt for negan and this really gives
the two a chance to bond do you see what
I did there really really clever on this
channel from the off though it becomes
apparent that she has been holding
things back and Carols planets entire
time has been to watch the whisperers
and by following them find out where
alphas horde is and destroy it
so that the wave of attacks will come to
an end once and for all this is very
much a stealth episode for the two and
they decide to enter whisper territory
on the condition that they Leave No
Trace kill no walkers and basically go
death stranding on the entire landscape
at the whisper campaign Egan is being
taken in for interrogation and it's
clear that his big mouth isn't going
down too well with the big boy baiter
who instantly distrust sin
his puts him into conflict with alpha
who wants him in the camp and it looks
like it's going to eventually lead to
her doing beta just wants to kill him
but alpha wishes to test him out to see
if he can be brought into the fold and
to become a worthy soldier with a mean
right swing it's clear in the cam that
everyone is second-guessing alphas
leadership qualities but nobody seems
strong enough to do anything about it
beta bends the knee and agrees to take
Megan out into the woods and see what he
can do beta gets negan to dig a hole and
the two kind of compete to some old rock
and roll music that definitely feels
like a massive like hard moment in the
show that is sorely needed beta seems to
best him in every way and it reminded me
a lot of college kids initiation tests
that get more and more ridiculous as
they go on however what way you slice it
though and slice it they do
negan shows that he's more than worthy
to be part of the whisperers and who
knows if they go the opposite way of the
comic you might even like it there beta
just doesn't seem to want him there
though and nikken confesses that he's
there for alpha this is in line with the
comics in which the characters said that
he was in love with the leader and she
balls for it beta pretty much rings the
dinner bell for the walkers later in the
episode with negan in the middle of them
and this causes the leather-bound bar to
be stuck in a very bad situation I'll
get into what happens later in the
episode but there's a lot else going on
that I need to discuss first Sadiq is
having trouble with his daughter and
it's clear that the guy is struggling to
be a father in a relationship that
doesn't really have romance in it what
with all is Ami's walking about and
stuff there's also a mysterious illness
in the camp that is slowly spreading and
it could lead to some big deaths if not
properly monitored it is clear that he
does still care about Rosita though and
will do anything for her and his baby
and he's got some competition too mainly
with Eugene who is working on the radio
using the satellite port in order to try
and reach other communities this will
definitely end up being the Commonwealth
but it's nice to see that everything is
starting to come together with the tying
of the two communities Rosita reaches
out to Eugene and once him back I'm
guessing she must miss having a
babysitter
or that treaty mean Kibum Keane trick is
definitely working what can I say the
ladies love a mullet just as much as the
men I love a bald head
we love you alpha he manages to reach
out to another community and it looks
like the Commonwealth may be brought
into the show pretty soon as they are
the next big community that the
survivors come face to face
for those who don't know they're pretty
much out where humans were before
everything shut down society wise and
have streets of shops barbers and
probably an internet cafe I don't know I
don't know where stuff was in 2010
anyway they seemed like a pretty
friendly bunch and Eugene is making some
connections with the lady on the other
end looks like it's too late for you
Rosita someone else has got your man
stuck on air on the road Carol and Daryl
make their play sneaking through the
landscape at night and they come
face-to-face with some walkers to get to
the bottom of what's going on
demon resorts the old up to my nuts in
guts trick but this time is a facial and
discovers that during the campaign carol
has managed to take a hostage which he
isn't too happy about
it's a massive risk that definitely
looks like it will allow outfit two
their plans and back at the camp a beta
is very surprised to see negan is alive
and well and strutting about like
there's no tomorrow I haven't seen him
this happy since he cave Glenn's head in
in front of Maggie and then took her for
his wife in Batman V Superman bit of
movie trivia therefore all the movie
fans out there make sure you subscribe
err I do love negan going off in full
style oh and peacocking for everyone
he's felt very toned back at some points
during this season preferring to get his
hands dirty farming rather than getting
his hands dirty doing what he does best
and its really felt a return of the old
character that we all fell in love with
all that time ago it's another pretty
funny moment with the character saying
I'm ready for my goddamn skin suit you
best bring that extra-long tape measure
on account of my humongous balls I kind
of get the feeling that alpha is really
taken with the character and he's a
breath of fresh air in the Lonely Hearts
Club that is the whisperers shouting
loud and proud whilst they keep their
volume to a minimum he really makes a
difference and is a great guy the
character bends the knee for alpha and
she seems very smitten with him and beta
looks on realizing he's just been
friend-zoned could say who doesn't love
a bald head and the episode ends now
going forward this is very much in line
with the comics and if you haven't had a
chance to read them then we're going to
end up ruining what ends up happening to
alpha so you may want to turn up the
video if you don't want anything spoiled
however in the books
negan joins the camp as we've seen and
builds a friendship with alpha getting
closer and closer to the leader he
professes his love for her and she seems
really taken with him however it's all
the play by negan to stab her in the
back or front and one night when the two
are talking he gets her to break down
and in this moment of weakness slits her
throat killing her instantly it
definitely looks like the show is
playing it this way and with just two
episodes left this year I can see this
being a potential avenue that the
creative team decide to take especially
with house to phase at the moment now
going forward it looks like the hostage
that Carol took is also going to help
divulge where the hoard is though
getting the answers out of him it won't
be easy I can imagine that Carol and
Daryl will have to partake and torture
in order to do it but we all know
they're more than capable of doing that
as for Sadiq something seems to be
driving him insane and it's very likely
that the character was instrumental in
the attack on hilltop that so many
characters end up with their heads on
spikes
I believe that Sadiq was behind this and
the Alpha forced him to do it as it
seems like it would have been difficult
for her to do this on her own
and she would have needed help she may
have blackmailed him and this could
definitely come out at some point in the
future and show that he's not the long
soldier that everyone thinks he is
it definitely has me excited for the
next episode and things are slowly
starting to wrap up I was expecting a
big blowout for the whisper war that it
doesn't look like we are gonna get but
as far as setup this has been pretty
engaging even if it has slightly lack
the main things that I was hoping to see
it does seem to be going in line with
the comics and with the Commonwealth
right around the corner we could be in
store for some amazing complex I'm
guessing that's where Rick will be too
as hey it just makes sense for that rich
group of people to have helicopters and
stuff so this seems like a likely Avenue
for the show to take that introduces new
characters in order to keep things fresh
now obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on the walking dead so far and
what you hope to see in the upcoming two
episodes comment below and let me know
and if you enjoy this video then please
give it a thumbs up and make sure you
check out my full breakdown of the
series so far which would be linked at
the end we go over everything that you
need to know about the season and give
our predictions for where it's heading
so it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to know more if you want to
come chat to me after the video that
make sure you follow me on twitter at
definition whitey or head over to my
discord server which would be linked in
the description below those are the best
ways to keep up to date with all the
ways
videos on the channel so hopefully I see
you over there very soon we're also
giving away a free copy of the Marvel
phase 3 part 1 box on blu-ray which
contains Civil War Doctor Strange
homecoming or Ragnarok and more and all
you have to do to be in with chance of
winning is to like the video make sure
that you subscribe to the channel and
leave your thoughts on The Walking Dead
in the comments section below the
winners gonna be chosen at random on the
15th of November and the set will be
shipped out from then till they get
surprise so best of luck to everyone who
takes part this is the channel for
people who are never missing television
so if that's the kind of thing you like
you need to subscribe to definition
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this you've been the best and I'll
see you next time take care peace
you
[Music]
[Music]